so is it fair to say that biden's the
president
is it is it official okay i'll go live
i'll go last yes so so what are we all
over what do we all owe here so if bite
is
here you go all right stay up on the
podcast don't ever come back and say
and pat doesn't pay patrick beth david
just paid me a thousand that's a
thousand dollars for you
thank you of all money feels good it
feels good it's really good that's real
money your
marker and find out what it is so you
got your money save that money
uh but uh with that being said um
obviously georgia happened and you got
democrats
defeated uh uh ossoff defeated purdue
and uh uh and then you have warnock who
defeated uh
lafleur uh by the way i have a lot of
friends of mine that went to uh
morehouse
warnock is a uh morehouse uh a graduate
himself shout out to all my friends who
went to morehouse
this is a very big victory believe it or
not for morehouse university because
you know um it's it's a elite university
they develop leaders and these types of
victories gives a lot of credence and
credibility
to universities so what do you think
about what happened with georgia and
what's gonna happen now okay so george
is really really interesting because
you watched the fallout from this
because a lot of people are blaming
trump
they're blaming trump for repo this
should have been a slam dunk this should
at least been a layup for one republican
to be elected in georgia yeah i mean a
democrat hasn't been elected a senator
in the state of georgia since 97 1997 or
96 was the last time
it happened now they blamed trump
because all his talk about the election
being stolen
and voter fraud made a lot of people
feel like why vote
i mean it's already predetermined so
there's some some credence to that
argument and and some top
republican officials are really pissed
off at trump and they blame him for this
now there's another side that blames the
republican senate
because they feel if they had approved
the two thousand dollar stimulus checks
if they had gotten those checks for two
grand out game over
one of them wins the other the other
blame game that's going on is
loffler ran an uninspiring campaign they
weren't really thrilled with what she
did
and then purdue was actually running ads
talking about some insider trading
situation that he was involved in so
harping on some negative things so you
have the combination of
bad campaigning on the ground the fact
that these two thousand dollar checks
didn't get out it was only 600 because
mcconnell and his boys prevented that
from happening and then
trump's constant harping on fraud on
fake on steel
let a lot of people to not vote we're
talking georgia yeah sorry i've been
counting my money yeah
thank you for that that's respect uh
there is no chance no way i there's no
way the republicans should have lost
both seats in georgia
no chance like that is a buffoonery
do you agree with him though on who's
responsible for it he said there's a few
things responding yeah he said trump
yeah he said the senate's because they
didn't approve the two thousand dollars
you know so it's it's do you agree with
that the two thousand dollar thing i
think
you know that came in the last week or
so tail end but you know that's
important
oh i disagree there because they've been
talking about that since the summer not
2000 bro they talked about 1200 at one
point
they've been going back and forth on
these stimulus for for for months now i
don't think the 2000 thing
trump floated the 2000 thing himself
what he wanted listen
here's what happened in georgia who's
the governor of georgia what's his name
brian kemp yeah okay he was a massive
trump fan yeah trump got him elected
um he's been behind trump the whole time
he ran against stacey abrams stacey
abrams is
a huge um voice in georgia
on the left lots of influence lots of
influence
cool cool cool he's been saying he's
been
obviously because there's been an
election they're stoking the flames of
what's happening in georgia they've had
three recounts in georgia they did a one
by hand recount
he still lost he won two three strikes
are out trump
and again they're talking about being a
sore loser he lost in georgia
and he blamed it on brian kemp and you
had the secretary of state of georgia
come out make an impassioned speech
being like
somebody's gonna get killed somebody's
gonna get killed talking like this
so when you're talking about a rigged
election you're talking about you need
to win these seats in order to take back
the senate
and they should have won at least one
are you kidding me david perdue are you
kidding me
um and you're saying it's a rigged
election you're having people uh
the the trump's attorney in georgia
what's his name uh lynn wood
you've seen this guy yeah coming out
basically saying don't vote
unless these uh senators
come out and and do something about this
rigged election
like one thing that you said at the
beginning at the beginning of this was
whether you agree or disagree the
democrats had a unified plan
republicans have been fractured whether
it's the lincoln party over here or
whether it's trump
making fun and and picking fights if
there's one thing we understand if
you're going to win elections you got to
be unified and the republican party is
not unified right now whether you agree
with
democrats or not they had they were
unified behind we are beating trump
the bernie sanders wing the aoc wing the
elizabeth warrens they
came to the center with the joe manchins
and the bidens of the world
and they said look we're going to be
trump and they've had a unified message
trump
fractured and that and look there's no
way that they should have lost they
played
fricken georgia and they did okay so
what happens now let's talk about what
happens now they lost it what happens
now they own
all of it for two years it should not be
like what happens now
how what like if you were to say so you
go into the mind of a democrat okay just
go think like you're a democrat right
now what are they doing right now
what are they doing right now which
plans are they going after right now hey
i don't think that the democrats are as
unified as a lot of people think they
are they have huge fractions right there
and and you know
your squad and some of those people are
really pissed off that they're not
included in the cabinet
all eyes to me are on joe biden how are
you going to handle this
are you going to take this this
advantage that you have and try to ram
everything in or are you going to be a
little bit more sensible i will say this
i was impressed with him yesterday you
know he was less
radical with his statements than obama
did you read obama's reaction to
yesterday i mean
my god i mean it was completely over the
top you're saying biden no
obama obama had comments about it too
all the past presidents did but i
thought biden was measured
i thought he was all right and you know
what so far
look he i'm so grateful that he hasn't
put any of these really really radical
lefties
uh in in serious cabinet positions or
positions of influence yet so
i'm watching biden to see what he does
with this don't try to ram
every crazy idea that's been floated out
there in the next two years now
the other thing i say is i just give
props to our founding fathers because
they put a system in place where we can
do something about it in two years
so i think you got you got to suck it up
and deal with whatever it is um that's
going to happen for the next two years
but you got a chance to make a
difference
you know starting with these house
representatives uh elections coming up
but it's
biden i'm praying that you're a sensible
have a voice what will he do though
give me by the way obama yesterday said
history will rightly remember today's
violence at the capitol incited by
sitting president as a moment of great
dishonor and shame out of our nation but
we'd be kidding ourselves if we treated
it
as a total surprise is what he said and
biden said i call on president trump to
go on national television out to fulfill
his oath and defend the constitution and
demand
uh an end to on this on the stage
uh uh to the siege so what's gonna
happen well go specifically
here's some specific meaning number the
only thing that matters right now
is getting the economy back and and not
freaking out about covet anymore i mean
as serious as it is
and it's a huge problem there has to be
a legitimate plan to get the country
open and running again
you even look at andre or andrew cuomo
in new york now i don't like him
i don't agree with him but he's doing
some things to open it up i just saw
yesterday the governor of minnesota a
democrat
waltz opening up bars opening up
restaurants
coming back having a plan the worst is
california
i live it i know it it's it's terrible
but biden cannot take advantage of this
to put further hindrances on everybody
in this country that's already suffering
i think that was a big part of what you
saw yesterday too
a lot of those people that have lost a
lot of things and have not
you know lost their job they have no
hope ran to washington d.c and went a
little nuts
but uh you and we have crossed a point
now where there has to be a plan
to get the economy going and figure this
thing out so your number one is economy
what i'm what i'm you have to realize
guys this is deeper than
that the democrats have a genie now
in a battle okay you make a wish you got
a lot of things on your side
house senate and presidency is yours
okay
uh we have we forgotten about packing a
court yeah we've forgotten about that
have we forgotten about capital gains
going back up have we forgotten about
taxes have we forgotten about
censorship have we forgotten about uh
breaking apart uh
companies such as uh uh the uh uh what
do you call it facebooks of the world
have we forgotten about what's gonna
happen with amazon have we forgotten
about a federal minimum wage have we
forgotten about
you know what's gonna be their first
thing that they're gonna say guys let's
go get these
obamacare you know what's the first
thing that they're gonna come out and
say let's get these things
sanctions on china sanctions on iran
nuclear there's a bunch of things that
they're going to do how much is going to
get done in the next two years
so i have a maybe a different opinion on
that
look the margins are razor thin so
there's going to be like my guy joe
manchin in west virginia i don't see him
just
toting the company line on increasing
taxes or example or anything with the
second amendment
or anything like that so the margins are
super thin i mean one i mean
kamala harris has the deciding vote uh
vote in this everything will be voted on
with her but i don't think it's going to
be as 50 50 50 50
as is projected here's my concern
because all those things whether it's
taxes whether it's
infrastructure whether it's minimum wage
whether it's obamacare those things will
be left to debate
here's my biggest concern we all saw
what happened in 2000
when the election was delayed gore bush
bushcore what happened what happened and
then
it took bush you know longer than
expected to become inaugurated what
happened
and then obviously 911 happened here's
my biggest concern at least
initially we we we're hearing rumblings
that iran was trying to
fly a plane into the capital right our
enemies are laughing at us right now
russia what are they gonna do okay i
wanna know what are they gonna what my
concern is
tell me is that trump is not going to
actually give biden's team all the
information that he would actually need
to
run smoothly and that something very
ugly
can happen i don't think that man i
don't think that's how does that not
matter i don't think that matters
how does that matter let me explain to
why that does something like 911 happens
that doesn't matter let me explain to
you why that doesn't matter here's why
that doesn't matter
okay america is bigger than one guy
you you just have to understand
america's bigger than one guy when a
transition is taking place
all the information of the transition is
not on one guy it's on everybody and the
people around them so
okay then those guys are going to
transfer the information of course
absolutely
so it's not this is america he's already
not holding out he's already holding
information he
is not everything the information is
the alone can fix it remember that oh
again you're being sarcastic i'm trying
to be serious to your answers i'm
serious
the information the information will be
given to the next guy
biden they're going to be all right i'm
not worried about that part you guys are
getting away from the point okay let me
ask the viewers maybe i'm gonna ask the
viewers i'm gonna say something else
look
dems have it all right now gang they
have the senate they have the house they
have presidency
what do you think they're gonna go after
and say cause today they're waking up
saying we got it all
what are we doing what do we want do
they go press the court right now it's
what six
three is on the right is that what it is
the paris yeah no no supreme court
yeah six three six three six three is
scary and six three is not five years
six three is not two years six three is
30 years 20 years so a long time right
that you're
looking at so do you go attack that and
say let's bump into 11 let's bump into
13.
do you go after uh you know a uh
medicare for all do you go after you
know second amendment background checks
heavily you know
training do you go after taxes raising
you do you go after what do you think
they're going to go after now they have
to move
where do you think they go what's your
biggest issue with yourself
so that means that means abortion means
packing a court yeah okay i think that's
a problem okay i agree with that
what do you mean abortion the rover's
weight is only the land
don't no yeah but the supreme court is
six three right now so if they wanted to
kind of make a move they could
make a move the supreme court is not
just going to bring up another someone
but the right could bring something up
and they're not thinking about the right
majority in congress they're not
thinking right now i just
told you that this is supreme court
could be like that for 10 20 30 years so
it's not it's more important than
presidency
they have to bump it up to 11 or 13 and
put two or four their own guys in there
i don't think that's going to be the top
priority okay i don't i hope i'm wrong
i think they're going to go after some
pretty aggressive things because i think
they might be thinking in a couple of
years
things could flip so i think it's paris
accord for sure taxes are a given that's
already done
how high will it go well we already know
it's going higher
and then based on their reaction to
kovid we got to keep everybody safe we
got to raise more money to give people
more money
they're going to keep going higher and
higher and higher um
healthcare i mean any i think anything
that they can get their hands on you
know he's going to be very ambitious
they always talk about a president's
first 100 days
i think they're going to grow throw some
things out there now that they have the
handcuffs off and they can basically say
and do anything they want and then they
have the media
you know presenting that message and
pounding it home to everybody every
single night
they might they might go a little nuts
here in the first two years well i mean
let's just go off what biden said he
wanted to do
clearly they're going to re-enter the
paris accord let's talk about what is
going to happen not
they may pack the cord they may do this
he said he's going to re-enter the paris
climate agreement
john check that off the box they're
talking about a
federal minimum wage increase to 15 i
fully disagree with that
certain cities sure federally uh i think
that's a horrible move it's a scary
thought taxes
will increase potentially uh if you make
more than four hundred thousand dollars
that's part of his
economic plan uh potentially capital
gains tax we talked about that
uh what i think and this is a good thing
in my opinion
you know remember when when when trump
took office in 2016 or early 2017 what's
the first thing he did
he went after obamacare yeah he went
after obamacare and everyone said what a
dumb move
to go after trying to go after
healthcare when you had a layup going
after infrastructure
i think biden is going to recognize that
and he's going to go after
infrastructure
clean energy green i don't think he's
come out and he said he does not support
the green new deal he does not support
medicare for all he's come out and he
said that
so biden has looked
especially with his cabinet positions
and especially with his proposals and
his positions
he has looked very moderate i know all
the
the the the crazies out there what's
gonna happen socialist communists happen
with china
i think he's going to continue what
trump has he said
part of his plan he's going to continue
what trump is doing with the tariffs
but i think it'll be reassessed clearly
i think he's going to do what china
tells him to do i think he's
he's not going to be overly aggressive
on doing anything laughing
no honestly i just don't think he's
going to do what china tells him to do
so you so you think so okay so what does
that mean though
do you think tariffs are going away with
china not anytime soon no
what's not anytime soon it's 30 days six
months
12 months 18 months a couple years when
is late
two years i don't know do you think we
should keep the tariffs in china i do
think we need to keep the tariffs on
china until
china starts giving us the ability to go
and investigate what happened with
coronavirus and wuhan
until china is actually going to give us
the ability to go investigate
uh yeah if you want if china if u.s
makes you a half a trillion dollars of
revenue of tax revenue that comes your
way because of import export yeah
of course we're your number one customer
yes we want to know what happens so this
doesn't happen again because if we open
up the airports of travel from china to
u.s
we want to make sure you don't do that
to us again so why didn't trump initiate
that already
what i what it is investigation into
china
for him to start investigation in china
right now it's impossible to do it right
now why because it's not done yet
what's not done nothing's done yet
nothing's finalized yet
with coronavirus meaning you're saying
when corona is done well
this thing is going through right now
and everything when the dust settles
they have to go do a major investigation
six to twelve months from now they're
going back and forth and the other day
china was negotiating of how much uh uh
the the world can come and investigate
and do due diligence on what happened
coronavirus they're negotiating to give
you
limits on how much limitations you got
that's china
negotiating with u.s right now you're
not pretty they're negotiating with the
world health organization on the kind of
restrictions they want to give you to
come and investigate what happened there
yeah i do think that tariffs are a bad
idea if china's not being held
accountable
let's talk about a common enemy and this
is something that you've addressed a few
times we've got to stop fighting amongst
ourselves look at us we have different
opinions but we're talking we're
meeting in the middle we're tapping each
other up who are our common enemies that
we should be
specifically focusing on china's number
one enemy
china's number one enemy iran's got to
be up there
and russia's got to be someone you
always have to be careful with anybody
that has a nuclear bomb pointed at us is
our enemy
so north korea number four uh who's the
top five i think north china
iran russia north korea and one of them
i'm gonna say is an ally
but you have to be very careful with
that is maybe not an ally would be
turkey
what about the germans i'd be very now
be very careful with turkey
you know keep it close but i'd be very
careful with turkey turkey is a
very very interesting
dynamic right now they're part of nato
very careful they're
they're aligned with that they're in bed
with
enemies of u.s yes yes yes you got to be
careful with them yeah
got to be careful with them uh venezuela
it was it was
sad but ironic when uh was it maduro or
whoever in venezuela said
look at the united states like this is
who we're supposed to be taking lead
from are you freaking kidding me
when venezuela is saying that about us
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye